- Over to our first
guest, she's had a storied
career with projects like
'Casino', 'Total Recall',
'Basic Instinct' and 'Ratchet' on Netflix.
She just released a new memoir,
it's called 'The Beauty of Living Twice'.
Lets say hello to Sharon Stone.
(applause)
Hello, nice to meet you.
- Oh my god, what a big
deal it is to meet you.
- What? Are you serious?
- Yes it is a very big
deal for me to meet you.
I just think you're amazing.
- Oh, oh my god, I thought that was
going to go the opposite way.
I am honored to have you on my show.
How are you?
- You're so talented and
your music has had such
a powerful effect on
my life and I am such a huge fan.
And you are so talented.
- What is happening right now?
I feel like I'm being pranked.
I am so in awe of what you just said and
have no words. Which is
rare because I'm talkative.
- Right.
- Well, I have to mention this
because this just recently happened
so a well known singer recently posted
how inspired she is by you and I want
to bring this up because
I think its such a
beautiful thing when
you don't even realize
your impact, and you hear from someone,
well maybe like what just
happened to me with you,
I had no idea that kind of impact.
And Britney Spears wrote
something about you.
Have you guys met before?
- Well Britney wrote to me
a very long and important
poignant letter during a very
difficult time in her life
about the time when people
would recognize it for
whenever she shaved her
head wanting me to help her.
I was in a very difficult time of my life.
I couldn't help myself but
the truth of the matter is
we both needed help and she needed help
and I needed help and it's
the true fact of it is
it's very hard to be a
very successful woman
and not have everyone controlling you.
Taking your finances and handling you.
Women, and I'm sure all of
the young stars get handled.
You get handled so much that,
- There's a breaking point.
- There is a huge breaking point
and there is a point where you get broken.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And it's, the thing with Britney Spears
is so out of control and so awful
and you know I can say certainly it's been
very out of control and
awful more than once
in my life and I have certainly had it.
It's very complicated to
take control of your life.
It's very hard to get
control of your finances
and that's something that I'm
sure doesn't surprise you.
- No, I literally - it's
such a cliched thing
because it does happen to everyone
that I've ever talked with.
The funniest thing, if I ever write a book
which I probably never will.
- You have to, because I
think it would be really good.
- The only thing I will say is,
just being me was very difficult.
People were, that is just being who I am.
That's the most odd thing
I'll probably ever say
but just having so many people tell you
who you should be and, "no, this sells"
and "you've got to do
this" "you can't say that"
"Why did you talk about that?"
"Well, they asked me, I don't know."
They try to put you in media training.
I literally walked out of that thing.
The guy looked at my manager and was like
"Good luck."
Because I'm an open book and
I like being an open book
and I like being unfiltered
to a respectful point
obviously but it's just the craziest thing
for me and my experience was just being,
just being able to be me.
And I feel like a lot
of people have their own
versions of that whenever
you're, you know,
in the public eye,
especially at a young age.
But I agree, I think it needs to progress.
(audience applauds)
Her new book is called "The
Beauty of Living Twice"
so how did you come up with
the title for the book?
Well, because when I had
the stroke and the nine day
blane bleed- brain bleed - blane bleed
(laughter)
brain bleed, I did have that,
what they call the near death experience
which is actually like
you're dead and you're not.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- Life is very different after that,
it's very very different.
I've spent a lot of time with people
who had similar experiences
and I think we all
feel the same, that we're
still alive for a reason
and that we have more
purpose driven lives now
and of course you're less fearful because
you've already died, so it's like,
what are you going to do?
Kill me again, I mean.
I've been there and I
know what it looks like
and I'm not as afraid of
what you're going to do.
You're going to threaten me,
you're going to do this to me,
you're going to do that to me.
Whatever, I'm already dead once.
- I bet when that first happened though
were you terrified?
I've had friends, that
things have happened
that they were terrified
for the longest time
whether it's cancer,
whether it's an aneurism,
something happening to where
it's a near death experience.
It's almost like, was
there a bit where you lived
in a little bit of fear because,
you know, you have family.
- Oh, I couldn't have,
I could have done the
triple cow sow and won
the gold medal in Olympics
of paranoia for probably a decade,
and still I can be triggered you know.
- When you were recovering
from your aneurism
your son did something,
and I've had moments
you know, moments in my life like that.
A lot of people can relate to this.
But what, what was the
moment that your son came in
and said something and
you were like, "whoa."
- It was the greatest thing
and he's still like this
going on 21, I was in bed,
I'd been in bed for months
and months and I was so
struggling, I was such a mess
and he came in, in his little onesie
and he's just standing
on the floor by my bed
and he looked at me and
he you know, waddled over
and pushed over the fireplace tools
and made this huge, just
like my head hurt so badly.
And then he looks at me and he goes,
"No more jammies, mommy. No more jammies"
- I love that.
- And I realized no matter how I felt,
he needed me to get my ass out of bed
and I was like, wow, okay.
I have to be a mom no matter
what's happening to me.
I don't think if he would have done that
I would have pushed
myself so hard to recover.
You know, he's going to
be 21 and he is here, just
he is the most amazing
person and he is the most
full of self of discovery,
he's so evolved.
He's such an evolved deep person.
- That's a proud moment,
that's a proud moment
as a parent to have
parented a kid that ends up
like that.
- [Sharon] I love my kids, it's
such an interesting journey.
- There's nothing cooler.
I mean I could win any
award or do whatever
there's nothing cooler than, first of all
my kid looking at me
and thinking I'm cool.
That's the coolest thing, you're like,
"okay I'm doing something right."
So, what do you hope people
take away from this book?
Because it's a lot to write a book.
I've had people ask me and
I'm like, "Oh God, I can't,
that's a lot of pressure."
What do you hope they take away?
- Well I just hope that they understand
while it's not an easy
journey to come to terms
with yourself and you're
not going to come out of it
with the same people in your life.
It's a valid and important
journey and it's a journey
that will leave you with your
feet firmly on the ground.
You get to have yourself, you get yourself
at the end of a journey
of real self discovery
and real sincerity and you
will find as I've found,
you stop making up
for your own,
the faults people say you have, you start,
you stop thinking I
have to fix everything,
I have to fix everything for everybody,
I have to make everything okay
for everybody all the time.
You end up thinking, if I'm okay,
if my feet are on the ground
then all the other adults
should be taking care of themselves too.
- Yeah.
- And when you finally
start giving back people
their own, you handle your own thing.
You adult for yourself, people
will go berserk with that.
Like, what do you mean you're not going
to be my
- [Kelly] Crutch.
- bum wiper?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know?
- Then suddenly you're free to be present,
fully present in your own life,
then all those other great people
who are present in their
own life are available
to hang out with you, so
you have a whole new life.
- That's a hard thing
to do what you just said
is to break away from
those habits of trying
to help fix people or help them and then
you end up hurting them
because you become a crutch.
And that's a hard thing
to do what you just said,
- It is, especially when
- So everybody should run to the bookstore
and purchase this book,
that's what I'm saying today.
Well everybody, Sharon's book is called
"The Beauty of Living Twice"
You've got to check it out, it's out now.